[Música]
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
reporteros de france 24 comenzamos en
esta edición hablaremos de los
separatistas de las regiones anglófonas
de camerún en áfrica que declararon la
independencia de manera unilateral hace
tres años y que hoy llevan más de 1000
días en una imparable espiral de
violencia en el sur anglófono al que
llaman ambas son ya las imágenes de
masacres inundan internet en una guerra
de guerrillas los militares del
presidente paul biyá el gobernante con
más años en el poder en el continente
africano están siendo cuestionados el
gobierno separatista en el exilio
incluso acusa a villa de genocidio
páginas hondo es una de las reporteras
de france 24 que estuvo en la región y
nos acompaña en esta edición para
entender lo que allí pasa y empiezo por
preguntarle estas una historia compleja
con un creciente interés internacional
qué obstáculos tuvieron que superar para
lograr ir hasta allá
uno de los obstáculos que encontramos
cubriendo esta historia fue la seguridad
no bar y canadá acceso destruir nadie
tiene acceso a esta región y menos
personas que vengan del exterior sin
escolta militar aunque estábamos con los
militares no fue fácil un convoy militar
fue severamente atacado del suroeste al
noroeste de la región la mayoría de las
personas que viven allá le temen a lo
que desconocen como lo vimos en el sitio
donde muchos we be soft underground
invitados entonces a ver el siguiente
reportaje
[Música]
en las paredes las secuelas de un
combate callejero en la carretera los
vestigios de una batalla feroz desde el
silencio de las armas un retorno
progresivo a la vida a lo largo de la
arteria principal de kona ciudad del
suroeste de caber un teatro de guerra
reciente entre los separatistas
angloparlantes y el ejército
militares en patrulla regular en este
eje comercial a pesar de la calma
protegen los convoyes de mercancías y
pasajeros en esta región angloparlante
en la que en octubre de 2017
secesionista soñaban con instalar la
capital del estado llamada ambas son
[Música]
desde el principio de esta insurrección
armada esta iglesia presbiteriana había
sido abandonada por sus fieles pero hoy
en día estas familias regresan poco a
poco al país ex desplazados de guerra
que se preparan para celebrar la fiesta
protestante de las cosechas finalmente
de regreso a casa tal como georg que
había huido de los combates para
refugiarse en el bosque según la onu el
conflicto desplazó a 680 mil personas
y tantos desastres pero le rogamos a
dios para que nos ayude para que la paz
regrese en las masacres terminen
queremos decirle adiós a las matanzas
queremos paz para poder reconstruir
nuestro país
camerún tengo casi 70 años y me siento
camerunés moriré pronto y me van a
enterrar aquí en camerún no conozco la
palabra ambas son ya es extraño para mí
solo conozco cameron
arriba de kona se encuentra el tanque de
dios sobrenombre del monte camerún o la
cumbre que domina esta parte del país
cuyas dos regiones angloparlantes están
en crisis desde hace más de 1000 días
para pasar del suroeste al noroeste
acompañamos a estos blindados ligeros de
la unidad de élite del ejército
camerunés el más solicitado para
garantizar la seguridad del trayecto
de conocimiento personal de cuidado
paquete sospechoso en este itinerario
vigilado de cerca por el capitán ibrahim
dio el oficial se prepara para un
eventual ataque al convoy por parte de
los grupos armados secesionistas los
atentados con explosivos improvisados
constituyen una novedad en este
conflicto que toma el aspecto de una
guerrilla
y durante los meses anteriores la
carretera estaba repleta de emboscadas
tras haber desplazado a la población los
secesionistas ocupan las edificaciones y
se ubican en emboscada para dispararles
las fuerzas de defensa y seguridad a los
convoyes las autoridades administrativas
tuvimos que actuar para reducir este
tipo de amenazas
una amenaza disminuida pero no
totalmente eliminada
de repente el convoy es el blanco de un
francotirador en buscado
más lejos pueblos enteros reconocidos
como bastiones de milicianos
separatistas armados llamados voice
reclamé estábamos enfrentando
secesionistas que reclamaban la
independencia del estado virtual de
amazonia pero al día de hoy le estamos
haciendo frente a personas fuera de la
ley
responsables de exacciones ante la
población bloqueos de carreteras
secuestros y que exigen rescates es
decir que pasamos de la secesión al gran
bandidaje
[Música]
en eso
en la parte delantera de la caravana
disparos de disuasión para prevenir
otros ataques tres horas más tarde nos
encontramos en la otra provincia
angloparlante la del noroeste último
feudo de los grupos armados separatistas
nueva salva de disparos sobre el convoy
quien responde
al final del trayecto para menta ciudad
símbolo donde empezó la protesta contra
el régimen del presidente villa hace
tres años y medio pero antes de
degenerar en conflicto armado
la protesta primero fue pacífica
las primeras manifestaciones anti
régimen tuvieron lugar a finales de 2010
y seis profesores magistrados o abogados
reclaman más profesores angloparlantes
en sus regiones la aplicación del
derecho de inspiración británica y el
respeto a su identidad en un camerún
bilingüe para protestar contra lo que
viven como una marginalización organizar
operaciones ciudades muertas cierre
obligatorio de comercios circulación
prohibida casi cuatro años más tarde
ciudades muertas sigue paralizando la
ciudad pero son menos seguidas en otras
ciudades de las regiones angloparlantes
no sin filtrar hemos a pie aquí
el nivel del objetivo principal romano
en bamenda romanus es el nombre de
guerra de uno de los presuntos líderes
de un grupo armado separatista fue
localizado gracias a una información
esta noche tiene lugar el último
briefing para una operación de
infiltración
obtuvimos informaciones según las cuales
hay muchos centinelas durante la
infiltración nos corremos el riesgo de
que nos hagan abortar la operación de
switch y unos bucles yo estuve
no sé yo
[Música]
no cree que haya riesgo de jugar nuestra
prioridad debe ser evitar un error
y prisa
la operación moviliza a una veintena de
soldados de este comando antiterrorista
que conduce a una guerra contra la
sombra perseguir a los jefes insurgentes
que huyeron de los pueblos y fueron
ubicados en los centros urbanos esta
delicada misión para detener o
neutralizar a romanos le fue confiada al
joven teniendo muy hondo tambo
el gran peligro es el hecho que los
secesionistas estén escondidos entre la
población se vuelve complicado maniobrar
porque si respondemos mal y un civil
caído todo recae sobre nosotros
[Música]
como el segundo estás en el último
vehículo adentro vamos
la infiltración tendrá lugar en un
suburbio de bam en una zona habitada con
un riesgo potencial de víctimas
colaterales un riesgo presente entre
todos aquí varios informes de ong se
censan desde 2017 las muertes de decenas
de civiles inocentes en medio del fuego
cruzado de separatistas y soldados
está bien pueden pasar en ciencias
visitar las bases en silencio en
silencio
en la noche oscura bajo la lluvia en
medio de campus y en un terreno
accidentado avanzamos con el comando
durante más de un kilómetro antes de
llegar cerca al blanco sin hacer ruido
después de campos necesitamos
y son muy peligrosos al menor ruido
cualquier señal extraña una disparan
paraguay instó a vivir un poco como el
sapito
la primera parte del comando aprovechará
el ruido de la lluvia para ingresar a la
casa sin ruido y sin disparos
cuando todos
[Aplausos]
en el interior acompañamos al segundo
equipo que penetra en la habitación
[Aplausos]
en el suelo se encuentra un hombre que
parece corresponder al líder separatista
buscado
[Aplausos]
haciendo
está solo en esta casa que parece un
hábitat fue sorprendido porque cuando
llegamos la lluvia lo arrolló dormía
tranquilo se sentía a gusto entonces no
podía creer que esta noche podíamos
llegar
entrar y capturarlo en la mayoría de las
ocasiones cuando habitan una casa es de
paso máximo dos o tres días y luego se
va
al final del operativo confiscan un
fusil semiautomático y municiones de
grueso calibre para estos soldados es
una prueba de la evolución de los grupos
separatistas quienes contaban con un
arsenal artesanal y ahora cuentan con
armas de guerra
un aprovisionamiento en armas facilitado
por la geografía de la región en este
paisaje de selva entre picos montañosos
y bosques densos tierra de nadie en la
frontera entre el noroeste angloparlante
y nigeria una zona fronteriza vigilada
este día por el teniente coronel frank y
plan quien dirige a la unidad de élite
pero si nos vamos a ver las bases de
datos de las miserias
ese pueblo que ve ahí el diferente la
frontera está materializada por tramos
de agua y tal como puede ver se puede
cruzar por todas partes aprovechan para
aprovisionarse en municiones y armas de
manera fraudulenta es una frontera que
no está delimitada es muy fácil ingresar
a nigeria y regresar a cambiar un por
distintos lugares
el helicóptero aterriza en el último
pueblo camerunés antes de la frontera
puro agua
recientemente reconquistado tras meses
en manos de los separatistas en la plaza
del pueblo están los restos de la
escuela quemada más de 77 instituciones
escolares fueron destruidas en las zonas
angloparlantes donde la educación ha
sido suspendida
el centenar de niños del pueblo no ha
tenido clases desde hace más de mil días
los separatistas quieren un boicot del
sistema educativo cameruneses que acusan
de corromper y afrancesar sus regiones
expulsión son sé que su principal
problema es el reinicio de las clases es
muy importante les ayudaremos para
obtener sillas y pupitres
[Aplausos]
[Música]
entre la gente hay padres desesperados
que quieren que sus hijos sean re
escolarizados
en la región 5000 escuelas están
cerradas y un millón de niños
desescolarizados son huérfanos huérfanos
como ellos que pasan sus noches frente a
la pantalla
entre ellos hay invidentes
charlotte le salvó la vida hace unos
cuantos meses escondiendo los en el
bosque para huir de los combates
de datos
se llama milagro fue abandonada en las
sabanas no sabemos nada de sus padres
están muertos han sido asesinados
pudieron escapar no lo sé todos pasamos
seis meses en el bosque fue un infierno
bus al punto de que un día los niños me
dijeron es mejor regresar y morir en
casa que morir en el bosque los
mosquitos el hambre la falta de agua te
lo aseguro
con infiernos
[Música]
sí
si el gobierno pudiese reiniciar las
clases hacer que llegue la paz sería una
gran causa
overbooking
[Música]
impulsar el regreso a la escuela
esperando precipitar un regreso a la
normalidad es la estrategia de estos
militares que tratan de ganar la batalla
de los corazones apostándole a una
ruptura entre las poblaciones y los
secesionistas separatistas armados
invisibles pero decididos a conducir
esta guerra de usura en las zonas
angloparlantes difícil hablar con ellos
por razones de seguridad en cuanto a los
principales líderes políticos
independentistas están encarcelados o en
el exilio
mil días después su app a sonia sigue
siendo un sueño y me acaba
regresamos con una de las autoras del
reportaje que ustedes acaban de ver los
líderes exiliados de ambas son ya han
presentado 100 casos de abusos de
derechos humanos a la onu acusando a las
fuerzas del presidente villa de tortura
y ejecuciones arbitrarias es una
situación compleja en este momento
y ascender
es una situación muy compleja ambos
bandos se acusan mutuamente
y sus 'slots' a cada vez que hay una
masacre o un homicidio colectivo los
soldados acusan a los separatistas y los
separatistas acusan a los soldados antes
ser persistentes y nancy wake
the shoulders wing bilingüe actual y
realmente no sabemos quién comete estas
atrocidades a menos que haya una
investigación independiente pero suelen
tomar meses lo que deja los habitantes
de la región molestos y con dudas de
saber en quién confiar y en quién no
quieres no nos guste atrás están juntos
tras mi casa vos sos vos partís porque
las dos partes militares y separatistas
probablemente se disfrazan hay militares
vestidos de civiles o de jóvenes de
ambas sonia y separatistas vestidos de
soldados que llevan a cabo estas
matanzas y sólo ser precisos países
culturistas sólo se encargan de ser más
yerimah vicepresidente de ambas sonia en
el exilio ha descrito a cameron como un
estado fallido y está pidiendo la ayuda
de la onu hay alguna evidencia de que el
presidente paul biyá quiere hacer la paz
y esté dispuesto a ayudar al pueblo
anglófono a mantener su cultura
descripciones aire cálido sol sin time
esta pregunta llega un año después de
que se celebró el diálogo nacional para
resolver la crisis anglosajona hubo más
de 1500 personas que vinieron de varias
partes del país a participar pero un año
después cuando miras lo que está pasando
en la región no puedes ver que el
gobierno tenga bien a estas personas you
can't believe that the government just
the estipulado
no tienes happening o look sin hacer
nada ha pasado se espera que las
personas vuelvan a las escuelas
especialmente los niños después del 5 de
octubre pero es realmente incierto
incluso que las personas puedan salir a
las tiendas a comprar alimentos o que
los niños puedan ir a estudiar y se
queden en casa
in the world
quiero resolver esta crisis el
presidente probablemente va a tener que
venir y hablar con ellos así como
cualquier otra persona lo haría
gracias a regina das hondo por
acompañarnos en la emisión de este
reporteros a ustedes también gracias por
estar con nosotros y recuerde que puede
ver esta emisión en nuestra página web
más 24 punto com para ver esta y las
anteriores emisiones hasta la próxima
semana
[Música]